[Music]
to give you a quick context of where
zipline stands
we should take a step back and look at
the machine learning workflow
of a data scientist so you start with a
business problem
and you try to find data and turn them
into features
and then go about training a model right
and you
keep doing this in some sort of a loop
until your model shows good performance
offline
now once you have this training phase
done and
a good model you try to move on to
serving that model
or to put it in production in some sense
so you need to solve the features in
some sort of feature store and you need
to solve the model
and then the application consumes these
two things put puts them together
and starts using those predictions
for different use cases so this is a
really elaborate process
and it's a multi-disciplinary
problem in some sense so turning
raw data into features is something that
a data engineer typically does
and using those features and generating
the model is your math phd or data
scientist
and then productionizing them is a
systems engineer of some sort
who sets up the database and then also
creates the model serving fleet right so
the problem big head in general is
trying to solve
is making this uh
large path so if you look at this paper
from
google it basically claims that about
95 percent of the work that you need to
do
is gluing together different systems
to serve this model and features
right so and about five percent is the
actual ml code that a data scientist
needs to write and solve for the
business use case
now in in that context the goals of big
head
are basically enable the data scientists
to do it all
so eliminate the need for a data
engineer and need for
systems engineers and do it with best
practices
so releasing models is a bit tricky
it's a bit more complex than releasing
general software
we'll talk about that in the rest of the
slides
and also make it efficient so generating
these features and models is really
compute intensive and time intensive so
make this
efficient and also save time for the
data scientist
so basically the goal is to automate the
95 percent that i showed in the last
slide
so in this context zipline deals with
the future engineering side of things
so why is feature engineering hard so in
our survey internally at least about 60
to 70 percent
of the time you spend is on feature
engineering stuff
and like prasanna mentioned in the intro
a good data with a simple model
is better than bad or inconsistent data
with a really complex model
and this is uh shown time and again so
for
for the longest time the google gmail uh
spam filtering is a really simple name
based model
they just had enough data to classify
what spam and what's not
and the other thing that makes feature
engineering really hard
is that your data is not static so in
when you do a kaggle computation or
whatever
you have a neatly ordered csv files
but in the real world data doesn't look
like that it's very
dynamic in the sense that every day new
data keeps arriving
and through kafka and through
hive so the real hard problem is to
incorporate that data into features
so before we talk about rest of facial
engineering it's a quick
here is a quick primer to data warehouse
so the actual real data
it starts from your service fleet and
production database
and this gets into this message bus land
as event streams and gets logged as
event logs and data like so message bus
is for example kafka
and data lake is your hive which is on
top of hdfs or s3
just to give give you an example and
similarly for production databases there
is a
change stream or the mutations or bin
log
then there is a corresponding change
capture log and similarly
there is a database snapshot so in some
companies they call this db exports so
it's a
midnight snapshot of the database that
lands in your warehouse
then there is derived data
so a bunch of other teams and a bunch of
external data sources
merge together in interesting ways to
produce some derived data
so and then there is media so your
images
audio clippings videos whatever
the unstructured data in some sense
if you look at this picture closely we
are going to consider
two groups of data in particular your
service data so the event stream and the
event log
and your database data the change
capture stream the change capture log
and
so i'll call this change capture
mutations interchangeably in the rest of
the slides
forgive me for that and then there is
your database snapshot
in the whole setup what is probably new
for most of you in this talk is the
change capture stream and change capture
log as
first class citizens in the warehouse
but it's an emerging pattern and it's
really
important for leveraging real-time data
in general not just in the context of
machine learning
and then there is derived data so
it is important to note this because
there are some data sources
in a company that cannot be real-time
just because
you're joining with various external
data and
there are transformations that are
opaque to you that you cannot replicate
in a real-time setting
so this is going to be midnight accurate
or snapshot accurate in some sense
and where zipline doesn't help is with
media
so if you are extracting features from
images or
audio or whatever into embeddings you if
that is the only thing that you are
doing
then zipline doesn't isn't really
necessary
so let's start with an example let's say
i'm trying to
recommend the restaurant and
i'm making up some really bad features
so the first feature here is
the total number of visits to
that particular choosing in the last
month and the average rating of the
restaurant in the last year
so the observation here is that most
features are aggregations right so
i just expanded the last slide to show
what those aggregations
are and to put it in the context of the
slide before
where we talked about the data warehouse
structure
the first thing is total visits to the
same cuisine last month so it's a count
of visit
grouped by the cuisine and window of
one month so we are saying that there
are two
things here one is the check-in stream
the other thing is a check-in log
and the stream being in a message bus or
kafka and the log being in hive
and this is another example where the
second example which comes from the
database side of
things so there is a ratings database
somewhere and it gets snapshotted into
hive
every day end of the day and then there
is a
mutations stream so
for uh you for some of you who are who's
not
aware of the mutations story or change
data
story there is this neat little tool
called debusium
that you can slap on your database to
extract the mutations in real time
the tricky part is leveraging these
mutations into computations and that's
where zipline comes
into play so these are some uh
real zip line examples so you specify so
it's pretty much what i showed in the
last slide
instead of you know putting it in sql we
kind of hijacked the aggregation side of
things for reasons you will see later
and we let you specify almost the same
thing so you'll say
what's an even stream what's an event
log and what's the query
and you specify what are the keys
and you specify the aggregation so there
is a way to specify the windows and
you can document it and similarly for
the
database source
right let me not dwell on this too much
and at the end of it you say all of
these features are now joined together
to create this feature set and we call
it a left outer
join but in some sense this is the
larger feature set api
right so before we uh go into how all of
this works internally let's
take step back and understand how this
data is
computed so visually speaking let's say
i wanted to predict or like recommend
you
a restaurant at some point in time a
label arrives to me
which basically is from the check-in
stream it tells me whether you went to
that place and
gave that place a good rating or not and
meanwhile there are features that keep
changing which is the average rating of
the restaurant or
how many visits you had for that
particular cuisine in the last year
so at the end of all of this prediction
stuff you would log it
to create training data set
right and similarly if i were to predict
at another point in time when you
check your phone again for example then
the features
change and the aggregations over those
features change and then you create
another row
with the same label
so if you look at this closely this is
some sort of a
join with the feature data and the
labels or prediction times and
while joining you're also doing a few
aggregations
so this is why it's called a temporal or
time series join with aggregations
so if we quick so we're going to quickly
look at the feature serving side of
things and jump into how we actually
compute this
before you even serve so first
definition of feature serving is what is
the value of these features
at this point in time right now
so the problems here are this needs to
be optimized for
reading optimized for point queries
and there is a subtle difference between
freshness and latency freshness is
when it's real time latency is how how
long does it take
to read and you achieve freshness by
incorporating
the kafka data or service events and db
mutations
we will talk about why we need batch
corrections as we go
go through the rest of the slides but
that is a pretty
important detail as to why the design
is in a particular way
so to recap all of that again really
quickly
there is uh fact style features and dim
style features so if you remember the
check-in stream is fact style data
and the ratings table is some sort of
dims you could argue that it could be
fact 2 but most companies they store
ratings tables or reviews table as a
dim table in some sense and you put them
together
so you put the change stream and the dim
snapshot to create
the other group of features and in the
first case you just put together the
fact log and the fact stream
which is the most common pattern so it's
over so it's aggregations over service
events
to get real-time features
so the serving architecture and zipline
is pretty straightforward so you start
from that definition
that i just showed you of the join and
the group buys
and the feature store basically has two
parts the batch side of things that
comes from the
warehouse data and the streaming updates
that comes from
kafka so we use flink to generate the
streaming aggregates and update the
feature values and then there is a model
servers
which serves these features to the
model and generates predictions for the
application
so there is a color coding here all the
blue things of various shades are
related to zipline and so
feature declaration is something user
provides and zipline generates
the pipelines that create streaming
aggregates and batch aggregates that
update the feature store
and there is a zipline client that is
embedded in the model server
which is read by this model which is in
green the green color coding is
basically
big head so it's the non-zipline part of
the project and then the
purple thing is user facing things so
if application engineer wants to embed
this predictions into his application
you just make a call to the model
to get the prediction
so this is your typical lambda
it's nothing new but we'll see how
aggregations make this lambda a bit more
nuanced
so there are two ways to go about
actually
so the first thing is we are now able to
serve features so
the second thing is how do we compute
those features for training because
training comes first right it's not
serving one way to go about these
features is to actually log them
you created this serving infrastructure
and as you serve you just log the new
features that you want without actually
using them into the model
it's really easy to implement it's
really consistent
but the real kicker is that it takes
a long time to gather enough data for
your new feature
to create a new model and sometimes
so based on what kind of business you're
in for something like airbnb you need to
capture seasonality
and that will mean that we will need to
wait for about six months to one year to
actually generate decent data to
create a good model so our goal here
in zipline is to instead of
relying on the log and weight approach
instead compute
the features as if
you log them so with full consistency
without having to wait for a year years
worth of time
so in that context of the definition of
feature computation
is given your feature definitions that i
showed you in the previous slides what
are the exact feature values at various
points
in history right so
let's say this i'm taking the same
example so there is a user and a
restaurant that
i want to recommend and
there are different time stamps at which
the user check their phone to look at
the
recommendation or whatever and given
so given the query log this query log
and the definitions
automatically fill in the right side
right so before we go into
the final topology of how that
aggregations work
over spark let's do a simple intro to
the
aggregations themselves so some
aggregation
has a nice property some is basically
adding two things it is commutative you
can
reverse the order and it's also
associative you can break up
a series of sum of n elements into
smaller chunks arbitrarily
and you can compute them partially and
add them up later together
and another interesting property is that
it's also reversible let's say events
fall out of your window
or whatever you can just subtract them
right and in category theory terms this
is what's called enabling group
so average also has similar properties
especially if you factor the
intermediate if you create something
called an intermediate representation
and
maintain sum and count separately and at
the end you do the division
so it's not a breakthrough idea yet
and one additional constraint that
zipline
adds to these aggregations is that it
needs to be constant
memory or bounded memory
so there are two classes of aggregations
actually so what we showed some average
count etc have this
reversibility property but min max
you know and some approximate unique
counting using hyperlog log or whatever
don't have that property
so again some category theory terms but
the real difference is that one one
group the first group sum average and
count is reversible
and min max approx unicorn etc are
non-reversible so you cannot delete
elements that fall out of a window
if you just maintain the aggregate
right so just to demonstrate or like
visualize what i just said
it let's say you want to
compute visits or check from the chicken
stream of a user for the last
year as the window slides forward
you just need to subtract the elements
that fall out of the window and add what
came into your window so zero comes into
the window one falls out of the window
and you can simply update eight to seven
so that subtraction is really key in
us being able to do this sliding
effectively
so how do we do this with irreversible
uh
aggregations like max
so one interesting observation is that
as the window slides we really don't
need to
look at all the underlying elements
because
before the window slid it did some
aggregation so we could somehow reuse
those aggregations to compute the new
window
and one way to exploit some of that
structure is to impose a binary
tree of sorts so i just cache
the intermediate values of uh
in the binary tree so in some sense to
move
slide the window forward i need to look
at certain specific nodes
and sum them up together and if the
nodes don't exist just compute them and
store them
so we are trading off some space for
[Music]
getting the speed but
the we are basically trading off
logarithmic we are achieving logarithmic
time
instead of linear time by trading off
linear space
so this is basically some table of where
we really need
those aggregations so if it is
reversible and if it is unwindowed
if it's unwind you don't need the
reversal but if it is windowed and if
it's not a reversible operation you need
the tree
logic and another context where
reversibility comes into play
is uh change data we talked about
how we can use uh change stream or
mutation stream from a database to
create real-time features
so the database change stream
has updates or deletes which basically
translate to us having to do reversals
so in some sense let's say a review
gets taken down so that rating value
needs to be
subtracted from the average or reversed
from the average
right and that's the context where
reversibility also comes into play
and this is the reason why to
incorporate reversibility
or incorporate mutations we need to give
different guarantees for reversible
versus non-reversible aggregations
so going back to our example i'm just
putting this here before we go into the
next part of the slides so the left side
is query log and the right side is the
final output that we want to compute
from raw data
so in that context a feature backfill
has
this structure so the left side is the
query log the right side are the events
and the output is the aggregated
features and the schema of the left side
i'm simplifying a lot here is a key
and a timestamp so the new concept that
we are introducing here is the key
so if we go back the user is the key for
visits and the restaurant is the key for
average
rating last year
right and the output is aggregated by
these different keys so the keys also
change
and the idea is so one way to imagine
how to do this
aggregation is to roll back your
warehouse data to different points in
time
run the aggregations and compute the
results but that is really really
slow and interactable in some sense
that would translate to basically two to
three months worth of spark jobs which
don't exist spark jobs don't run for so
long
they own before uh a few days
so it's really important that we uh
optimize these aggregations
and another observation here is that the
raw data that we
aggregate over is much much larger than
the query log
so the right side is really large left
that is
relatively small so we can use that to
determine how we design our spark
topology
so before we go into the spark topology
stuff let's take a
simple it's it's not so simple but
this is basically what i uh
what you would need to do on a single
machine so
imagine the raw data and the query log
are
two csv files on your machine now you
need to
take those csv files and compute the
final results given our
aggregations you would need to do
something like this it's a nested three
level for loop
and you look at so you do the bear join
and you try to go over all the query
times and then
inside in a for loop go over all the
events and if it is in the window
you update the aggregate
right now this is really really
expensive because
it's quadratic in terms of queries and
events
right so to and also
you're passing over events multiple
times but we said events is the
largest side of things
so what we do the first set of
optimizations is to actually only pass
once over the events
so instead we switch the loop so we
switched
the events and the query loop and then
we are doing the update differently
so here i broke the complexity down into
two parts
one of them is the search and the other
one is the update so
we are searching through all the queries
and we are updating as many candidates
with the payload in the events
and the second optimized week
optimization we can do is
actually reduce uh
the search complexity so we can do
something like binary search if we
assume that
the queries are sorted with time that we
can do beforehand and we can
use that for all the aggregations
right so b search here stands for binary
search it's nothing
fancy and the complexity goes from order
of queries to order of log of queries
right but but the real problem here is
actually updates updates are more
expensive than
search itself so can we
reuse that reuse the
logic that we looked at beforehand to
optimize even the updates
so the idea is again simple we invoke
this tree merge thing
so as we are passing through events
and as we are updating these queries
we instead of updating all the
candidates of a search result we only
update the
logarithmic number of tiles that tile up
the entire
event span so if i'm updating from 4 to
instead of updating all of these
individual seven things
i instead update only three things that
are highlighted here
right so that makes the code looks
look like this but it's still on a
single machine and it doesn't really
handle
the scale of data that we really wanted
to handle
so the next step from going from here to
the
spark topology is to try splitting this
out into different stages
so here if you see we call those
intermediate things styles and we have
these three separate looking stages in
some sense
so there is a stage where you collapse
the tiles so you updated the
intermediate nodes
but at the end of the day you still want
to generate uh
each row for a time stamp so that
collapsing is what
collapses all the tree into underlying
cells and then there is
another function which is tile range so
given a range so
in the previous thing the range is 4
to 13 given a range comp compute the
tiles that i need to update so the
logarithmic number of tiles
so in that sense there is basically
three stages
in the topology from left to right the
first stage is basically
creating the query types that are sorted
by the time stamp
then broad doing a broadcast join so
broadcast join is when you
know that there is a really small side
of the joint so you just send the small
side over to the large side
and when i say the large side you're not
really keeping all of that data in
memory or just
passing through chunks of that data
into memory and aggregating them into
the
broadcasted thing and then collapsing it
finally into actual values
so these are roughly the three stages in
the spark topology i won't uh
go into too much detail here but
it's just uh here for the sake of
completeness if you guys want to refer
later
so that's basically the crux of
my talk and if we take a step back
this is what the architecture looks like
so you give
me a feature declaration or give zipline
a feature declaration
it creates those feature backfills that
we talked about
right then you use those feature
backfills collect
labels if it needs to be collected
separately and then train a model
and then you go to serving
right and then you take up with
[Music]
the application so we talked about
serving first because that's the easiest
to understand
and explain but backfill happens first
so we don't log in wait we actually
compute these things